Si sabemos que, la recta A, tiene esta ecuación.
La recta B contiene al punto 6, -7.
Y la recta A y la recta B son perpendiculares.
Este dato creo que va a ser muy importante,
que son perpendiculares.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la ecuación de la recta B?
Y bueno, lo primero que quiero que recordemos es
¿qué significa que la recta A y la recta B sean perpendiculares?
Bueno, la recta A y la recta B, son perpendiculares
si la pendiente de la recta B, es el inverso
multiplicativo negativo...
el inverso... inverso... multiplicativo...
multiplicativo... negativo, de la pendiente de A.
Es decir, que la pendiente de B es el inverso multiplicativo negativo de la pendiente de A...
de la pendiente de A.
Esto también lo podemos ver
de la siguiente manera,
que la pendiente de B por la pendiente de A,
esto sea igual a -1.
Estas dos formas son equivalentes, es lo mismo decir,
que sea el inverso multiplicativo de
la pendiente de A o que la multiplicación
de estas dos pendientes sea igual a -1.
Y bueno, yo sé que la recta A tiene esta ecuación.
Entonces, si la recta A tiene esta ecuación,
su pendiente es el valor que está al lado
de la "x", es decir, 2.
Esta es la pendiente de la recta A y la voy a ocupar,
porque si ya sé la pendiente de la recta A,
la pendiente de la recta B, tiene que ser el inverso multiplicativo de la pendiente de la recta A.
Entonces, la pendiente de la recta B...
la pendiente... pendiente... de B.
¿Cómo tiene que ser?
Bueno, la pendiente de B, tiene que ser igual
¿a quién?
A la pendiente de la recta A, pero tiene que
ser el inverso multiplicativo.
Entonces, el inverso multiplicativo de 2,
es 1/2, pero además tiene que ser negativo,
por lo tanto tiene que ser -1/2
con un signo contrario.
Una tiene que quedar con signo positivo y
la otra con signo negativo.
Ya tengo la pendiente de la recta B, por lo
tanto, vamos a decir que la recta B,
tiene como ecuación "y" es igual a "m", pero la
pendiente ya sé que tiene que ser a -1/2...
a -1/2 por "x" más "b".
Ahora, lo que me falta determinar es cuánto vale "b"...
ahora lo que quiero saber es cuánto vale "b".
Pero para sacar a "b" voy a utilizar el otro
dato que me dan, la recta contiene al punto
6, -7, es decir, que este punto, como está
en mi recta B, cumple esta ecuación,
o dicho de otra manera, cuando "x" vale 6, "y"vale
-7 en esta ecuación.
Entonces sustituyendo este punto
¿qué me va a quedar?
"y" vale -7, entonces -7,
esto tiene que ser igual a -1/2...
déjame cambiar de color...
a -1/2 por "x", pero "x" en este punto vale 6,
entonces a esto vamos a multiplicarlo por 6 más "b"...
a esto lo voy a multiplicar por 6 y
a esto le tenemos sumar "b",
entonces a esto le voy a sumar "b"
y así voy a obtener el valor de "b".
Lo único que tengo que hacer es despejar a "b",
me queda que -7 esto tiene que ser
igual a -1/2 por 6, esto es -3 más "b"
y de aquí sumo 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
me va a quedar que "b" es igual a -7 más 3, lo cual es -4.
Esto es igual a -4.
Entonces ya sé el valor de "b", el valor de
"b" es igual a -4
y entonces ya puedo escribir de una manera ordenada, la ecuación de la recta B.
La recta B tiene como ecuación a la expresión,
"y" esto es igual a la pendiente,
pero la pendiente es igual a -1/2, recuerda que este
-1/2 salió como el inverso multiplicativo negativo de 2.
Esto hay que multiplicarlo por "x"
y le voy a sumar "b" pero "b" vale -4.
Y por lo tanto, lo hemos logrado, ésta de aquí,
ya es mi respuesta.
Y por lo tanto, no hay más que hacer,
nos vemos en el siguiente video.